no no fine
I'm markiplier and welcome to the improv
challenge no this is the change in
project hi we had some leftover improv
scenes that we're actually really funny
but didn't fit into their own video so
here is a compilation of those funny
scenes and I'm saying funny a lot but
yeah I mean empty promises are just a
bunch of lies [ __ ] it's funny watch it
enjoy it you need to get all the gear
off the thing and start drilling the
holes with the nuke in the answer right
okay Bruce Lewis yeah I'm Bruce Willis
gotta blow this asteroid I'm Steven
Tyler's daughter I've always thought you
were the hottest girl on this mission
but let's not give up yet I'm your
daughter right - - I stand by my words
don't try to change my mind yeah I'm
about to die I gotta be honest at least
one time in my life this stuff off of
the ship Jada let's get let's get all
these puppies off the boat change
let's get drilling change
I once murdered an entire pod of
dolphins you know what
that asteroid would have done the same
and frankly that's what I tell myself
every night frankly since we're gonna
die I
I figured you know it's we can do
whatever the hell we want yeah we could
kill dolphins hey company we could let
this asteroid go and kill everything we
can one build children nine whoa
change well I mean the entire planet
could die a few kids go here and there I
mean it's not that bad well on the great
Simon I mean you can't do a few if
faster if it's a work ethic is gonna
kill literally all the children and the
people unless you go to children's build
away in the junk drawer change unless
you've got dead bodies piled up in your
pants change unless you can find the
sausage okay my sausage I'm saving that
for what we love it why did you
instantly start eating my sausage it's
delicious it's good space food it's so
much better than then I thought I had
time I he's honored better than to eat
other people's sausages god damn it
Tanya Tanya
my name is audience you know what it's
all a little hazy up here I think my
suits running out of oxygen
whistling is a war we should get
drilling yeah we should get drilling
[Music]
yeah that's a hole it's already
pre-drilled this is one of those three
drilled asteroids go Oh God really bill
is a favor on this one all right look
foot you sure did yeah got the cover on
it we haven't put the bombing safety
covers are no and falls in these
countries okay all right what do I do
with this bomb one of the numerous
pre-drilled holes this doesn't have to
be the one it's a perforated coming to
the first hole we find to be like yeah
that's the one Richard probably you know
search our options okay change I don't
know about that chase it's closing in
we're gonna pick fast which hold hey
yeah champion hole filler I remember
back when you were getting the greatest
hole filling that the world has ever
seen
I I said my daughter wolf she's gonna
fill the most important poll and I think
you should get the up instead you said
five dollars Steven Tyler's daughter
denied Sally's daughter the photo
ability Steven Tyler's dog right I'm
gonna fill the hole you're gonna do it
for you don't know why it's like some
hot dog change it's like throwing a bear
down change comes too big when you're
right you're right
one's just right it's like a Goldilocks
story up man well since we all I got
what like 30 seconds left until we hit
the earth
maybe we shoot Hilda pretty Jeet you
know the prettiest eyes Jesus Tommy
Hardy's daughter I love you
your father daughter shopping for a prom
dress
I just don't know which what I want dad
about this one do you think you could
show off a little bit too much up here
yeah it's too [ __ ] this is my favorite
one I've seen some Tower no no no no
there's just not that many options
what would you go with any of these
dresses go down to the floor anymore
let's go to the long dresses long
dresses and cover up the cover up the
top part to it do they make dresses with
sleeves you find me asleep you're sad
you're embarrassing me but some of it's
right over there she's gonna hear you
I don't care what's you see that there's
cheese for a just duct tape over her
nipples it's horrifying it's in style
dad don't care what's in style no no
we're gonna blow me the long dresses dad
I'm gonna trip I've never worn a long
dress with heels women have worn long
dresses for centuries women have worn
long dresses and of course it's and they
have didn't think you were like this dad
you look mom wear those things that
there's not much they're going down to
the floor dad I've seen it yeah well I
was married to your mom and she only
cheated on me that one time but of
always it was cool it was your twin
brother dad you look the same
she can tell the difference I've seen
him naked and there's a difference dad
you don't know would say if she were
here right now I'm gonna let you know as
soon as I find out I'll wait sugar I
said instead of bats for baseball use a
dildo his mom is a free spirit dad you
know just stuck up and stuck in your old
ways women should wear long dresses I
don't think so I want this dress or else
I'm gonna worry about the table my
nipples too it does we're going to worry
about the bottom my bad smell region
earth can just show really
call it that and that does sound what I
don't think your mother would say but do
you know what your grandmother said to
me about your behavior and the ducked
animal was crazy the highly Cyrus's do
you know what she said before she passed
no why don't you tell me she said my
monkey swallowed my car keys and I think
we both know what she meant she wanted
her monkey to be free too dad have you
seen the Kardashians on the TV no you
won't let me watch anything but golf
isn't that just peachy no it's not dad I
couldn't be watching fashion weekly I
couldn't be watching the Kardashians I
could be watching where to get nice
dresses like this unlike grandma's
wedding gown you gave me at home which
goes down to the floor and then some I'm
not eight feet tall dad why is the dress
that long well you're you're coming to
prom so you're probably a little bit
young for the wedding dresses for like a
fully grown woman remember what Phil
Mickelson said the last time he was on
TV one good thing I have a golf
I feel says lots of stuff he said to me
well he said of the screen which I felt
like he was talking to me
potatoes have skin I have skin and you
don't even find that I should show it in
fact what do you think what is wrong
with you I just want this dress and now
I'm wearing it maybe you're not mature
enough for prom I think security is
looking at this dad we should probably
get this dress and go soon I think you
should put your clothes back on and we
should go let me I'm gonna deal with the
security guard just put your clothes
back on sir
sir what's up my cranky crew
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you're going into battle wrong person
yeah oh I'm sorry
the battle old age you know what we
should drop these fake accents that we
were doing you're not gonna fool the
Scots like there's no way they're gonna
believe that whoa that's the bestest
racist probably what are we doing
lieutenant man I think we're close
enough now what I'm nearly pregnant
that's okay you know I went to law
school or whatever but I you know I
what's the mood a few times I I you know
bad cat real hungry yeah but I feel like
you know that brings people closer why
didn't you give me some of that cat but
you want something so got some this is
the blood end all right though this
isn't a cat at all oh oh [ __ ] this looks
like a horse testicle change this looks
like your testicle you know hey that's
why I feel we're so close why is your
ball civic well I mean I'm extremely
manly changed ah you know cancer change
oh it's just I keep collecting them and
I just add more I've got a bunch you
know what instead of eating this mm-hmm
I'm gonna use this to repel the Scots
I'm gonna use this
that's firewood Wow I you know I I feel
like that's a waste of my testicles that
I've been collecting for years now
I hunt they're highly flammable from the
middle but told you that who said the
testicles were flammable through your
wife said yours word I'm not married
change change did you grab them I
coughed should I turn my head Gregg no
you're great I'm great yeah Great Scott
lieutenant oh my god we're full great
work Gregg that's great I feel like we
could even be closer friends now that we
know each other Gregg's change open in
here by cloning them change
oh you're taller than me that's not cool
break that's not cool not while there's
war happening change
oh you know and just after a whole what
my bullet wound isn't good enough for
you my burden whole from you
laser hold of the experimental laser
it's in your pocket I just change was
attached when I got there testicle to
him and I knew I shouldn't chain my
lasers to my balls like that I keep
losing them that way oh well well you
know what I think we've forgotten the
more important thing at hand we're about
to die they're coming screaming their
Scottish screams oh sorry that's is very
hard change it's all right they're just
flashing us with their butts change oh
it's all right
they've nuclear bombs Shh they're really
far away you're right
but their nuclear bombs what their kilts
have grappling hooks but that's that's
not important what's important is we're
both great I feel like that's the least
important if we're gonna be the kragle
gonna be great small
or use our grenades but again grenade
versus a nuke I'm out of testicles I
just ate the last cat the situation is
grim I was only trying to cheer you up
because we're obviously gonna die
I was only trying to do a dance I'm not
good enough for that that's why I always
became a soldier my dad told me the same
but this war is one how one play dance
wow I don't understand how that
correlates but my dad always told me
that I couldn't dance change wow you
know my mom when she died of Lou said
uncle touched me when I was a kid
pushed me to be a soldier ah that's
impossible you speak impossible dreams I
don't know
are any more correct have you've not
seen the Nutcracker No
Oh anyway we need to win before we
doodle through dance fighting so we need
to practice again I'm not 100% sure I'm
on board with this but I'll give it a
try ready for you first
I got a stretch for a dance
they say stretching isn't enough you
need to be massaged during the
stretching that sounds pretty good Wow
but how many hands you guys we mind if I
make my own motion let me get the
testicle out of the fire
this brie burn right now princess ago I
gave you Church we gave you some a
collection well I just heated it up for
the lotion thinking process how does
that work we got nuclear Scottsman we
got grappling hook line losses I ain't
the last cat I can't dance
my uncle touched me it's all going to
[ __ ]
asthma grandpappy used to tell me I love
balls
you are two construction workers
building the world's talisman bhavo that
doesn't go there you say in this [ __ ]
huge eye beam that we just craned up
here spent two hours lining up doesn't
go right next to this [ __ ] huge eye
beam we just crane up here that we spent
two hours line up no it's saying that it
was over the left it didn't [ __ ] it 80
feet long you see this [ __ ] thing
what am I just gonna scooch it to the
left and that's why you took the
steroids no I took the steroids to get
the chicks okay I can't [ __ ] how are you
gonna get chicks with those tiny balls
and you can't move the freaking i-beam
we deal with that in the bedroom they
like the muscles I can tell you this I
was last night at the bar this hobby
this bond you know what she said to me
what I walked up showed her the gums she
said I want you to paint me like one of
your dead neighbors and I was like [ __ ]
she knows who I am before I even talk to
her how does she know you come on your
name I know right Phil the reputation
[Music]
this thing I beam are you sure this
isn't right it's what's right I think
it's the corner of the whole building
maybe it's upside down can you flip it
over at these fires [ __ ] it's still
pretty I'm sick of this you don't use to
say to me in these situations it's not
really gonna being mean used to say cry
like the baby you are that sounds
exactly like no
look I'm gonna do this well you just go
[ __ ] off you know I could call the
police I know about all the neighbors
got evidence of that kind of enables
foot right here well that's weird right
it's Johnny's the neighbor on the Left
why don't you ask about your
fingerprints you look you must have
killed them I didn't kill it give up
inside too bad I'm gonna call the cops
right now you know what you got that
guy's fun you'll cut the foot off you
want the foot I'm gonna call the cops
and then I had cops
once upon a time a boy was hit by a
truck and this [ __ ] guy I know he got
hit by that truck buddy then you gonna
tell me if you can't talk right no more
but it's still funny and you just move a
little baby [ __ ] off you know what
I'll wait I'll just take a little nap
here we'll be performin you have horns
and down 40 stories instead of doing
that I need you to do me a favor
probably not yeah do you know he said
you would do me this favor like two
weeks ago
sure you can jingle my bells and there
are two pirates who just discovered the
buried treasure you were digging up the
treasure chest to this MD this be it
yeah sorry I beat it you don't have to
do the exercise I got it oh thank you
kind of so tired of it eight weeks of
that on the seat you know they make
ships with turbines no okay okay this is
the last [ __ ] time we can intern
we would you'd use the shovel and open
the thing find her this bad joke
what is this one of those goofs you'd be
doing no I have no idea what you're
talking about I'm not one to goofy bro
I've seen I've seen the internet videos
of the goofs it's disabled
no God no I'm not a prank YouTube what
have you done with Nicole Jesus I don't
know I just got here I think there's
something written in there oh yeah oh
yeah there's some things like an
inscription oh yeah I hear weed is hip
with the kids these days why did God's
name with black squirrel have booked
that in this treasure chest well I don't
know black scrote seems like kind of a
dick
no that the whole thing about his name
is he had no dick oh I mean I guess he
could have acted like a dick I he's a
historical figure I didn't know the guy
are you telling it on my mom's side
already all right all right you know I'm
just confused about why did I sign up
for this I could have gone to Somalia I
could have gone anywhere
don't I need fake pilots okay they call
them Somali pirates they're [ __ ] guys
and [ __ ] duck boats taken over oil
tankers we're pirates we being denied
whoa okay yeah I know I but I mean I
went to four years of pirate in school
and I was about to finish I thought hey
I could study abroad for a long time in
my goddamn life and this is what it
comes down to my men
skee about then there's no way you went
to pirate school and they didn't teach
you the accent okay where's your ticket
read where's your diploma there's the
scroll I'm not graduated yet do you know
what's like say about people who lie
about going the Pirates squads did that
spaghetti out of your mouth fine you
want to hear about me pirate school
where search doesn't lift in there you
want to hear about my time at tiny
school you'll discover me soon I be
black scrote great Caesar's ghost
that's not a very piratey thing to see
I'd be so shocked I can't even their
Italian site is showing true truth your
beauties where's the gold or blacks
would like to know where to go this
truly I would whisper it in your ear I
just say it out loud maybe all right
fine I speak a lot you'd fancy still
down to it's concerning all right how's
it so black it's an octopus garden in my
pants it's down by Davy Jones locker
jeez you want your turn assure don't
[ __ ] come and get it how much gold is
wholesome probably a lot no like
concrete numbers ah it's hard to
estimate when it's dinkley round me
screwed if you want me to touch the
black screw answer me this
Oh am I you got me there I don't [ __ ]
know
fancy okay anyway we're done here
so that's it see ya and bye bye